let's start by the academy we teased
this a little bit
i think folks learned about it for the
first time in our overview video last
month
um so from your perspective you know
what's the academy all about
where did it come from what's the idea
behind it i'm really proud of the
academy concept
when we started the journey to you know
what was going to become halo infinite
we needed uh
i don't know if you know this but when
you go to play multiplayer it's
intimidating to a lot of people and so
we needed to kind of create a ramp for
how players get there and kind of
smooth that out along the way and so we
thought about like what are the
obstacles that players have to do and so
the academy is broken into like three
core parts and then kind of a fourth uh
extension to that but the first part of
the tutorial
where we teach you the fundamentals of
the game uh we'll introduce you to the
kind of the canon around the mp spartan
what is the player spartan's purpose in
the greater universe
and then the next step after that we
have weapon drills which we'll get to
play with and talk about today which is
cool
and those are really about kind of just
giving you a chance to put your hands on
a gun
in very simple settings really just kind
of mono focused right just really focus
on how that gun performs and learn and
there's different skill levels which
we'll get to see a little bit
and then the third part is the uh what
we call the training mode which lets you
play a cat
arena matches basically arena slayer
inside of all of our arena maps
and lets you run around and you can
configure the difficulty of the bots you
can configure your loadouts you can
configure
i don't know there's just a bunch of
tuning knobs to let you really kind of
soften the experience and then the next
step i would say beyond that is once you
kind of get comfortable in there as we
have four v-bot matches
um so we have four players like i mean
halo is a team-centric game so
we want players to learn how to play
together kind of first and foremost and
you do that against bots before they
kind of go start getting head shots
across the map
well you mentioned weapon drills which
is the sort of the slice of the
academy that we're including in the tech
preview today um i think we should jump
into a weapon drill or two i'm sure our
our viewers would love to check that out
firsthand i mean tom if you're willing i
maybe put you on the spot here i mean
let me see how much i can embarrass
why don't we each do it right so i'm
happy to go first josh if you want to
you want to jump back over to my my pov
here
um i've already kind of jumped into the
academy menu i'm presented with an
option for weapon drills you know i did
want to point out this is not the
entirety of our sandbox right this is
what's in the flight
it's a slice right so i would expect
more weapon drills so
you know i think i don't know like what
fans would be most interested in seeing
i'm going to guess they probably don't
need to see an ar weapon
right so let's do something a little
more exotic now this is i might do this
because this is my one of my personal
favorite new additions to the game
this thing is a beast uh it sounds
awesome
it feels awesome and real quick tom how
would you want uh viewers to understand
sort of i got three options here for my
for my weapon drill so there's three
tiers of weapon drills and the basic one
is static bots and they'll just stand
there
kind of just let you get the hands on
the gun right shoot the basic targets
and we'll score you on your performance
and kind of give you a grade so you
understand how where you're using with
that gun
the next here they're kind of on more
just like kind of simple paths or
crouching behind cover and things like
that to kind of
show you how to use the weapon get you
to move that next here howdy track a
target across the screen
and then the third tier is more they
actually are doing combat behaviors
they're not firing back at you but
they're running around and they're
ducking and they're
they're a lot less predictable and so
they're kind of harder to track they're
kind of using more of the actual bot
behaviors and mentality so i guess i'll
split the difference and go
uh i'll go like a tier two okay right i
mean don't judge let's see how you score
don't judge
a lot of pressure here and i mean safe
to say has been a lot of internal trash
talking as well right yeah we trash talk
a lot especially about scores like i
mean you know
we're a competitive team at our core so
that's what you have to do
you know and speaking of too i think
there is a cool com not only is this a
learning module
in a lot of ways but there is a
competitive angle to it and you know i
think
safe to say down the road the team's
thinking about possibility of things
like leaderboards and kind of how do we
really
bring that gamification competitive
element to this yeah that was something
that we really wanted in the core design
and just you know it just didn't
fit into the schedule so we're just
building the this kind of as a platform
for how we can add more over time
okay here we go all right not doing good
by the way that's something our fans
notice right there we have damage per
uh sort of location specific uh visual
indicators on damage right
yeah it's actually it's really helpful
right you can it really helps just that
pop where you're here look at that i
already i choked right there now are you
are you uh
are you a feather the trigger person
with this weapon or do you just sort
of pray and spray i'll just be honest
i'm hot garbage with this gun that's
that's first and foremost my problem
um i'm trying to get better with it i i
kind of use it as a like an
automatic but when i'm kind of at range
i'll switch to kind of the the
feathering
oh man that pillar got in your way that
wasn't that was not a great performance
two star i mean terrible i i think there
is a bonus for like a quick reaction
right like if i were to quickly zoom in
on the target right when it appears i
think i might get an extra i think
there's extra little bonus points and
little twists around it so
all right i want to put you on the spot
now we're going to switch over to your
point of view so you
so first of all okay going for the
controller right because we support
mouse and keyboard or controller doesn't
matter controller guy
whatever suits your fancy tom i am
hearing from our uh our friends over
here on the room that it sounds like
chat
is unsurprisingly very interested in
seeing the vr
uh you know i think that's expected
we'll let's bring up the br then
let's see how i mean i'm okay i do like
where you're going with the more exotic
weapons so so maybe we just kind of
break the rules and squeeze in a third
we'll squeeze in another one um i'll
i'll try to go the the third tier
so people can see kind of the different
behaviors and so you see there were kind
of more bouncing targets than what you
were doing
um so you'll see this they should take a
little more cover and stuff but yeah
obviously a fan favorite weapon i'm
really nervous how well i'm gonna score
let's see well at least we're picking
different weapons so we're not really
like we can't really compare each other
against
against each other right so
yeah people are already making fun of me
in the stream i can see it
i imagine at least i'm really terrible
about managing my reloads i'm like an
incessant reloader
that's either i probably shouldn't have
reloaded right there
well it's when we're missing shots like
you and i do it makes it a little hard
to be predictable on that right i know i
really feel like it's part of my job to
get better at this and i'm trying
and and i am getting better i'm a little
more better
like btb is kind of my brag but you can
see they're kind of dancing around a
little bit they're strafing more they're
not just
bounce patterns
i'm hitting headshots at least you
almost got this crap reload
time's up i think that's a pretty good
score well it's a new high score
compared to whoever else
yeah i think nobody so all right so
that's tier two
so rank two so yeah so you can see like
we're trying to
kind of give you some grading so you can
understand your skill level and like how
you can get better or you know a little
bit like kind of encouraging to get
better
so you can understand where you're where
you're meeting all right i think
i think we're getting a request let's
maybe take at least one more uh you want
to play one more since you're already in
why don't you do i mean
so i'm hearing that there's a lot of
interest in the heat wave this is uh i
don't think we've really seen or shown
this really to date so this is obviously
new and exciting
um a little bit unconventional right a
little bit different yeah it's a
different i mean it has an alt-fire
which is cool it's something that's kind
of new to halo
i know queen and his team was really
proud of that um and kind of how do we
introducing this kind of concept into
the game and how can we can use this
kind of more in the game
this weapon's really fun and the the two
alt modes or the two modes are basically
vertical and horizontal fire
um i can't remember how this drill
performs so
so see one of the things cool about the
drills um is a lot of they're trying to
do behaviors that actually encourage you
to
use the weapon correctly so like these
two were bouncing near each other
and so you can get a more optimal like
kind of horizontal shot
and i know folks notice it's pretty
nuanced there but i think you're using
your left trigger to sort of swap
between those two different
modes all right get together boys
and this will penetrate right so you can
line guys up and just take them all
very cool last shot suck there we go oh
i'm definitely not managing my reload i
feel like i have more time in the game
right like when you're in a match like
hide behind cover but this is definitely
that like kind of stressful
which is in a good way like it helps you
get better by
you know going through the repetitions
and the drills well the world watching
doesn't probably
yeah it doesn't help
i think i'm more nervous about you just
giving me [ __ ] after oops ah we're fine
that's all right we ran the esrb i'm
good
when the tech build goes out tomorrow um
the weapon drills will be available
right away so you
folks that are in the in the flight can
play to their hearts content all weekend
long we encourage you to do that
and i want to see people kind of see if
you can be tom's score there you go
let's throw the gauntlet out yeah
please i mean please beat my score
[Laughter]
if you don't i'll be disappointed